السلام
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى كلا انه تذكره فمن شاء
ذكره وما يذكرون الا ان يشاء الله
هو اهل التقوى واهل المغفره
يقول تعالى
كلا انه تذكره فمن شاء ذكره وما يذكرون
الا ان يشاء الله هو اهل التقوى واهل
المغفره
سوره المدثر
الله سبحانه وتعالى كلا كلا
للتنبيه
ليس
لرد ما قبله او لنفي ما قبله
قران
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
etر
رانفingat
made ofan
someate
froman
before
انه تذكره
قران
تذكره
عظه
يقول تعالى فمن شاء ذكره
يقول وما يذكرون الا ان يشاء الله
وجاء هذا بالتاء والياء يعني وما يذكرون
وفي قراءه سبعيه وما تذكرون الا ان يشاء
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
هو اهل التقوى واهل المغفره
سبحانه وتعالى نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
يغفر لنا وان يعلمنا
التقوى نساله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يعفو عنا وان يعيننا جميعا على تقواه
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد